[Música]
y en directo américa por supuesto
también hablábamos de salud y para eso
nos acompaña como todas las mañanas
nuestra periodista más romeros a la mar
o enviar coles para usted como está bien
pues madrugando pero bien con todo bueno
madrugado también es una buena noticia
para algunas personas y vamos a hablar
hoy de pakistán porque las inundaciones
se están poniendo en riesgo la salud de
millones de habitantes sí pues como
hemos venido repitiendo ya en estos
noticieros sabemos que un tercio del
país ha quedado bajo el agua y eso tiene
múltiples consecuencias una visión
general que vamos a hacer para empezar
por supuesto por ejemplo la falta de
comida no que agrava un problema de
desnutrición que ya afectaba al país
incluso antes de esta emergencia en el
hacinamiento también en los campamentos
la falta de agua esto pues es un caldo
de cultivo para que hayan más
transmisiones de enfermedades de hecho
ya se ha reportado por ejemplo
enfermedades diarreicas infecciones de
piel infecciones en los ojos también han
alertado de la posibilidad de que crezca
en enfermedades como la malaria o el
dengue que se aprovechan pues de las
aguas estancadas los mosquitos crecen
más así y los mosquitos como sabemos son
pues los vectores que contagian estas
enfermedades pero es algo muy importante
falta quien cuide a estas personas
porque pues porque según la ms hay 890
centros de salud que han quedado dañados
por culpa también de estas inundaciones
de los cuales 198 189 perdón han quedado
prácticamente destruidos entonces pues
también estas personas al final no
tienen a quien acudir frente a todas
estas enfermedades y dificultades que
están enfrentando y ahora a marc le
propongo que hablemos de un sector muy
específico de la población porque estas
inundaciones no están afectando de igual
manera a todos y las mujeres por ejemplo
son las más afectadas porque así es un
poquito saliendo del cliché también de
esto de que las mujeres y los niños
siempre son los más débiles de los más
afectados no es una cuestión de
debilidad sino de unos problemas
particulares que nunca se tienen en
cuenta a la hora de responder en estas
emergencias vamos a poner un ejemplo muy
básico por ejemplo la salud menstrual
hay un montón de mujeres y de personas
que me entran en pakistán que están
teniendo que usar por ejemplo ropa sucia
a veces hojas incluso se ha reportado
gente que usa arena para durante los
días de su menstruación en vez
higiénicas o cualquier otro método que
se pueda usar durante estos días no
además de suponer un problema de
dignidad e integridad física también es
un problema grave de higiene esto puede
llevar a infecciones urinarias
infecciones en los órganos reproductivos
entonces pues es algo que se tiene que
solucionar y que nunca está tampoco pues
en las prioridades a la hora de
responder a este tipo de emergencias
otro ejemplo son los embarazos hay
muchas mujeres embarazadas en estas
regiones afectadas por las inundaciones
y se espera sólo en el próximo mes 73
mil partos mujeres que van a dar a luz
sin a poder tener pues las instalaciones
que necesitan los profesionales médicos
que necesitan una de las afp por ejemplo
una agencia de noticias reportaban un
testimonio de una mujer que está a punto
de dar a luz vamos a escucharlo
y estoy de nueve meses donde debo ir
para conseguir medicamentos necesito un
médico o una partera qué hacemos si le
pasa algo a mi bebé yo misma me siento
débil me han recetado medicamentos pero
no los puedo pagar sexuales y otra de
las dificultades de los partos en estas
condiciones marc es la falta de agua que
también es una de las grandes
problemáticas que han dejado
precisamente estas lluvias monzónicas en
pakistán cuáles son las consecuencias de
la falta de perdona que te quitará y no
es que realmente es un problema muy
grave porque el agua tratada al final es
lo que sirve para higienizar por ejemplo
en situaciones de parto en cualquier
otro tratamiento médico en realidad pero
es que además tiene consecuencias a
veces tan mundanas que no nos imaginamos
pero que son muy grandes
hacen falta baños en la mayoría de estos
campamentos de desplazados donde están
viviendo las personas que han perdido
sus casas en las inundaciones eso qué
pasa pues hace que los desechos de las
personas vayan al agua de las
inundaciones
directamente y al no tratarse esta agua
luego las personas lo usan para bañarse
para limpiar la comida para limpiar la
ropa o incluso para beber entonces por
ejemplo también nos reportaban
desde uno de estos campamentos de
refugiados los problemas que ya está
causando eso
verify personas en hay 30 o 35 personas
con gastroenteritis una de las
principales razones es que no hay baños
la situación es que deben meterse en las
aguas de las inundaciones para ir al
baño así que hay muchas personas con
gastroenteritis con diarrea con vómitos
claro estamos hablando de consecuencias
muy directas maría clara de estas
diarreas que están haciendo ahora y que
de hecho es un ejemplo claro de los
efectos del cambio climático también
lado ms project a 48 mil muertes anuales
por enfermedades diarreicas a raíz del
cambio climático este es uno de los
ejemplos de lo que se nos viene también
en el futuro pero hay otra cosa que
preocupa mucho y es precisamente el
apoyo pakistán es un país donde esta
enfermedad es endémica el otro es
afganistán y precisamente es una
enfermedad que se contagia a través de
las heces de las personas infectadas que
vayan al agua y que las personas lo
iniciarán este virus entonces así es
cómo se contagia la polio precisamente
entonces vemos que es uno de los mayores
riesgos de estas
estas inundaciones además la lucha
contra la polio en el país ha sido ardua
vemos que han logrado más o menos
rebajar al menos desde 2014 los casos
que se han diagnosticado en este año ya
llevamos a 15 vamos a ver cómo termina
en el resto del año y bien como usted lo
decía amar hay una relación directa
entre la crisis climática y el repunte
de estas enfermedades sobre todo por
vectores y yo le cuento un dato y es que
pakistán está dentro de los 10 países
más afectados del mundo por la crisis
climática a pesar de que ha emitido
menos del 1 por ciento de los gases
contaminantes lo que muestra también un
desequilibrio aquí pero más allá de
estos temas ambientales que claramente
no es el momento para profundizar los
cuéntanos cómo está siendo la respuesta
ante la emergencia sanitaria en parís
está después de maría clara más bien voy
a justo lo que estabas diciendo
quizás para terminar también con unas
reflexiones quien debe responsabilizarse
de responder ante estas crisis tú misma
lo estabas mencionando vemos que
pakistán como decíamos emite 0 28 por
ciento de las emisiones globales en todo
el mundo históricamente mientras que por
ejemplo eeuu la unión europea y china
han emitido el 12 el 21 25 por ciento
pues respectivamente quien es el
responsable no al final de responder
ante esta mujer embarazada que no va a
tener como parir con seguridad de estas
personas que ya se están enfermando no
creo que cabe preguntarse estas cosas
cuando estamos frente mirando a la cara
a este tipo de crisis mart gracias por
este reporte